The Mummy is directed by Alex Kurtzman
and stars Tom Cruise and is the 17th
version of this I don't know there's a
lot of mummy movies and once again
there's a Evil Dead creature that's
roaming the earth and there's a big
sandstorm with a face and Tom Cruise is
going to run away from the mummy so yay
all jokes aside Tom Cruise plays Nick
who's sort of a soldier but more of a
looter he teams up with a dude named
Chris nice name played by Jake Johnson
and Jenny played by Annabelle Wallis to
solve an incredibly old mystery
surrounding a mummy played by sofia
boutella that's right The Mummy is a
girl this time around you know as I am
walking into this movie I really had no
idea what to expect it could go either
way for me the trailers didn't really
impress me but in the past I've not been
impressed with trailers for Tom Cruise
movies like edge of tomorrow and then
been blown away so I had really no idea
what was going to happen with this film
and leaving it it's fine ah the
excellent production design Tom Cruise
once again giving a very dedicated
performance sofia boutella as the mummy
the special effects the action sequences
all of these things are so good that
it's tough to call it a bad movie but
what really sinks the mummy in a lot of
moments where nothing amazing is
happening on screen is the screenplay
this is written by a lot of people
developed by a lot of people that's six
people and it shows because this film
doesn't feel like it has one real
emotional Direction certain scenes can
be really entertaining and would make
amazing YouTube clips that people watch
over and over again to remember that one
scene they really thought was fun but as
a whole this movie is really
scatterbrained and a lot of it comes
down to that screenplay
unlike cruises last movie Jack Reacher
never go back which I thought was one of
the most bland Tom Cruise performances I
had ever seen and was a major
disappointment here he is very
charismatic and actually quite funny the
screenplay does give him a lot of good
jokes but a lot of it relies on his
timing his comic timing in this movie is
actually really excellent and of course
as usual he throws himself into action
sequences like no one else
and he sells every single head something
painful moment of it Russell Crowe is
also in the film and I'm not going to
tell you who he plays because I honestly
did not know and so I try to keep the
secrets and the fun for you guys the way
I feel when I go into a movie and I was
excited to see who he was playing I
didn't realize he was playing that
character and he was definitely for
myself one of the brighter spots of the
movie and watching him share scenes with
Tom Cruise was also really fun it felt
like two really big heavyweight actors
just going at it and that was a lot of
fun to see Jake Johnson in this film is
kind of the comedic sidekick that's
always dangerous that doesn't always
work in fact very rarely does it ever
work when you have your main hero
protagonist that you're excited to see
doing things and then there's the kind
of jokey funny guy following him
everywhere and it's a gamble and it
didn't pay off I think that this
character is extremely grating ly
annoying and every time the character
was on-screen I just I really wasn't
enjoying it
beyond the screenplay my biggest
disappointment with this movie is the
character of Jenny portrayed by
Annabelle Wallis this is one of the most
useless characters I've seen in a
big-budget movie in quite some time she
is needing to be saved in every other
scene she really doesn't bring much to
anything in this movie rarely does she
solve anything she essentially carts Tom
Cruise to a couple locations he needs to
go to and beyond that she's a damsel in
distress
it's horrible timing to be coming out
the weekend after Wonder Woman a movie
about an incredibly strong girl made by
a great director who is also a girl to
have this character that is just so
completely useless in this movie was a
major distraction and it was just it's
it's like we've passed this you know
we're no longer in this stage where the
girl lead is just led around everywhere
and sometimes does a few things but for
the most part they are just constantly
unconscious it's like kind of sad
actually but in all honesty I am a fan
of the mummy movies I've enjoyed a lot
of them for a long time even the
original with Forrest Karloff burnden
Frazier's movies are
kind of guilty pleasures for me the
third was really bad the first one is
quite enjoyable Mummy Returns definitely
a guilty pleasure I mean have you seen
the CGI for the rock holy and the
Scorpion King
the Scorpion King is bad but I enjoy it
it's a bad movie but it's like the right
kind of bad movie so when I come to
these movies I don't walk into them
expecting them to be fantastic works of
art I just want to have some fun and The
Mummy this new version does have
sequences that offer it there's a lot of
exciting action sequences Tom Cruise is
very likable and funny in this role and
it's also a role that isn't
stereotypical Tom Cruise he's kind of a
dick he's a bit of an asshole and he's
no hero really he's just the guy that
was there when stuff went down and now
he's got to deal with it and I must say
I really did like sofia boutella as the
mummy I thought it was a nice change of
pace I thought she was great she is
continuing to knock it out of the park
in every role that I see her in it's
just that the screenplay is so
scatterbrained and the film doesn't feel
like it has much direction it's a nice
looking movie and I think audiences will
have fun watching it because there's a
lot of white knuckled sequences but when
it ends it just doesn't really feel like
it's built to anything it just kind of
feels like a giant setup for more movies
it has this horrendous unnecessary
exposition seen in the beginning with
Russell Crowe and he's not talking to
anyone in the film he's actually talking
to us like telling the audience of story
and it just makes no sense the film
feels like action scene then set up
scene action scene more explanations to
other things because we're all so
curious it feels like about two hours of
exciting action sequences that are also
looped in with a bunch of scenes needed
to explain or set up a future universe
which is this film's apparent objective
Universal once they're dark universe of
monsters I guess they're just kind of
forgetting that I Frankenstein and
Dracula untold we're really not good and
they're trying to do it again I got a
side although this one is fine I think
if you just had nothing else to do and
you could watch The Mummy and you didn't
really care about storytelling
characters and just wanted to watch some
fun scenes where Tom Cruise
runs away from giant mummy sandstorms
okay I'm going to give the mummy a see
guys thank you so much as always for
watching please do check out my review
of baby driver if you haven't seen it
already Edgar Wright's new movie I'm
excited about it and I hope when you
guys see it you are too there's going to
be a link for that in just a second and
I got to interview Colin Trevorrow for
his new film The Book of Henry and it
was really cool he was super
down-to-earth and a nice guy and that is
going to be up very soon guys thank you
so much as always for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck menage
[Music]